advancement through education is a myth
or is an illusion you do
n't have to have studied today to make your
way i've often noticed heard
seen from other interns that he
says yes i got the job
because if parents
corino but juso politics or toni
toni  mang german federal election
involved flipping the script
tried central of the wait and
politicians first on top picks shaping
the election
nike ist germany we can't recall of
eternity
arrangement company in my
financial services industry i have a
rock solid belief that you will be in
germany if you do it  really want
to achieve everything can it's just a question
of attitude can yes i know lisa
zimmermann and social advancement is
more difficult for me because i have had structural
obstacles in the course of my life
the others i don't think have yes
or no in germany anyone can do it
from the dishwasher  make a millionaire
whether you succeed or not  what is successful
is alive depends a lot on the inner
attitude and i have done it in the
past, that i approach people who
are where i wanted to be, people who
have had certain successes
that i wanted to have, i just
actively approached them and asked them
tell me what do you do exactly if i
don't have these people directly
in my environment i mean we have
a mega chance today in the 21st century
i wrote to the people once via
facebook on instagram so just on
social media he asks
tell me  what are you doing we can
maybe talk to each other for a moment maybe make a quick phone call not
everyone answers but one or the other will
answer and maybe give
you a good tip so that really complete
strangers just write to facebook
or linkedin without
your family network having any
or that you brought the school and
committed teachers with you  it
or just like that i imagine it
sounds unbelievable to me to be honest
but i think i of
course that's true i think
that's a myth so advancement
through education is a myth or is
an illusion
clearly from a legal point of view that the german
education system is very  permeable i
believe that you can definitely move up the ranks
but i believe that it is very difficult for some
groups for some social groups
that working class children
or if you now
think of classic hartz iv families
then maybe you can no
longer speak of working class children because
the parents don't even
go to work,
so there's a clear
difference
[music]
[music] well
, since I'm also
studying social sciences, I
also know that there are other factors,
not just origins, but
also family support
i think that plays a role in
immigrant families  h loyalty is
important yes and i think that maybe you got
help in the household
that i didn't get from him
and the fact that my father is long-term unemployed
obviously plays a big role in the
process of social advancement
[music]
[music
] just being in the act  if
you somehow try
to free yourself from this situation and
say i'll take the
initiative and i'd like to move up and i'd like
to earn something extra and
i have to go to work for it,
for example, then the law doesn't provide for it, for example,
because additional income in  the community of
needs is linked to a limit,
i.e. 100 euros plus 20 percent of the additional earnings that makes on the
basis of 440 euros earnings 170 euros
that you can earn
to be able to do something before an unexpected internship yes so when how ha  did
you manage that it was back then and we came
to
germany 27 years ago i was two
years old and my parents
came here as refugees and my parents
thought about everything clearly what do we do so that
we can also integrate here and also b
our butter and bread how we
earn it then my parents opened a
pizzeria step by step through a
lot of work through a lot of commitment through a
lot of diligence it became an indian
restaurant which we sold at some point and of
course i also worked in the
indian restaurant i was a waiter  I was
already playing pizza taxi question in front of the pizzeria
I did everything and
my father gave me 20 euros a day back then
so it wasn’t much money either
and I worked there ten eleven twelve
hours which doesn’t suit my parents have it today
the restaurant
sold normal jobs so a
worker my mum is a laboratory assistant
my father is a metal worker and ic  h started
my own business in the financial services industry
why did i
do it because i said i want to be
responsible for my own success
exactly we also clearly wrote to one
or the other person
on social media who might also
be more successful in a sub-area where i become more
successful  wanted was successful or
was already where i am where i am but
you probably only
liked that now maybe recently i
don't think you hated a seventh
grader who
looked up lehmann on facebook and wrote to
someone and said that hey you
you are my role model how can i become
like you what then i
honestly don't believe in it and i believe that in order to enable
equal
opportunities like this or at least to
equalize the opportunities you have to start really
early it starts in the day care center
and it works in the  elementary school
and I think what you tell me
is really wi  any valuable contributions
that maybe only noticed in the
recent past yes
or no the society has made it
more difficult for me personally than for others
here well
i think i am one of them
so although i may be a
working class child and i
still have problems with promotion  still one of the
privileged in this society,
yes, when I think about children and
young people who maybe
no longer have parents, against parents
are in jail or have
somehow experienced violence and abuse because they don’t work out
, yes, they definitely belong to the
privileged anyway  of
course i experienced
discrimination despite yes i still experienced discrimination because of my origin
was bullied at school
hence this mixed answer
and growing up in a hartz4 household is
also not entirely unproblematic
so it is clear that you are stigmatized and
you cannot take
advantage of all the opportunities to participate
at the  e have class
trips, for example, or when they don’t have access to
music culture education extracurricular
activities i said hey i
’m from india people have
usually always been interested
haye and they’re doing exactly like z i was
always relatively quick  with the
topic with the people, which was actually always
rather positive and I didn’t
really notice that I was somehow
great dumont or was
criticized that there was somehow
a joke among the boys,
but it’s clear that I now say
there  i feel him at a disadvantage i
felt that not at all
what i notice is that many
students from a working-class family
in that is absolutely missing vitamin b
so what is taught on the golf course, so to speak
, in
terms of internships or lecturers or whatever so
i notice that  we just don't have
this family background then
you've already
experienced it personally  bt that you just got a lot
but can't have a say because
you're not in this traffic I'll say to these
other
circles anyway yes vitamin b is missing social capital is
incredibly important and yes
I often missed it in life, especially with
praktiker  well i often noticed
heard from other interns
that he says yes i got the
job because if my parents or because
my aunt xy had
married her husband and he works as the
CEO or as a department head
that's why i think it's all the more important that
you have network programs or  climber
programs somehow promotes yes or
supports civil society organizations we see
when we look at the statistics that
quite a lot of people, i.e.
migrant people, also become
self-employed your parents
apparently have a residence status relatively quickly
they were able to
become self-employed what do
families do in  endure  g
are not able to become self-employed
so first and foremost i
would i would make sure that i not
only have a temporary residence permit
, but an
unlimited one, that i can also
work reasonably, that i can
earn reasonable money here
and maybe also  the answer the
question to the answer the the answer to
the question
why do many many people
with a migration background also become
self-employed believes that a change in
mentality
so that many people in india also
appreciate it very much socially
when other people become
self-employed or self-employed  are and
that's why it's always been I'd say I was
already six seven eight years old or
when I was in the seventh grade
was my goal but at some point in
your life you become
self-employed it's an entrepreneur at some point in
your life  always
somehow my goal
[music]
and maybe my parents were
self-employed it may also
have played a role that i then
said hey i want to do my
own thing no matter what i do
but i want to do my own thing
and i assume they are
strong too  supported in this idea or
they actually always supported me in what
i did definitely
that it just i think the difference
to certain ones so even the
climbers split up again into
groups of climbers who have this
family support and which ones
just don't have it and that's what makes the
belief the difference between us
admit
yes this what you describe
no one can argue away that it's
the numbers also show us that the social
background is still decisive in
germany unfortunately about the
chances of advancement but what you also
now clearly named several times it is that
you say the family background
is missing u  nd that's ultimately nothing
where politics so that's my
thesis can't do that much with politics
I think there's of course
also something that's already planned by some
politicians he's supposed to legally belong we
definitely have to come up with that but
my question  would be now you mentioned the
mentoring programs what can
politicians do to make up for the lack of family support, so
to speak, in his
opinion, i think it's hard to
put it there, you can
balance or align knowledge,
maybe for example, and that's of
course when it comes to education  and
i know we are
facing a big question in this country right now, how will
the education system in general
want to be designed after the pandemic and i
think scientists
now agree that, for example,
relatively early selection is harmful
for cohesion or for
the emergence of inequality
[  music]
[music]
and yes my approach would be possible
s  later selection and also
schools with multi-professional teams
yes, so more diversity not only teachers,
especially with regard to
teachers shortage of skilled workers, but also
other specialist skills it is important
for social advancement that one has
a social partner and if that is
not in the family then just that  through
network programs or through the
dedicated teacher or through someone from the
youth welfare office who
accompanies you in some way, but often, yes, I know,
I have the feeling that institutions are tied to
an act of logic and so
neither the youth welfare office nor any of the
clerks from the federal employment agency are
interested  for which
way to go
i just had a comment
on the question why are there so many with a
migration background who are
self-employed i think it's
great and i really think this
commitment is great i wonder what's going on
with us in germany that  we have so
little  en who
want to give up self-employment would you prefer this safe
haven from public service looking for an employment relationship
what can
we also learn from people with a
migration background there seems to be a
lot of courage and commitment to be yes
or no more than ten years of school
did not put me on a successful
career prepared yes or no
i recently saw a funny picture
on social media
fire there were cassettes that you put in
the car or something wortmann
heard today there is spotify and
various other apps and
programs 40 years ago there was a board this
board is there  it is still in
school today that we just
go further, that we maybe do
a little bit with digitization on the
one hand but on the other hand
maybe also offer subjects where
we support people in different
areas that we say today
happy mindset money attitude
that we have a money min  dset for
people to build on that they
learn to understand how do I deal with the subject of taxes
for people who perhaps
also recognize themselves relatively early on
, like I did then I
would like to become an entrepreneur at some point
that they might
realize how entrepreneurship means what that
means for  me how can i
become what do i have to do for it i think
school is of course an important place
the students of course
supported me because
logically i learned to read, write,
do arithmetic and that it’s just a place where
you are socialized of course yes and
especially im for  families or for children
who come from difficult families it
is a place of rest and relaxation
maybe yes and a place of
learning and i wish
that school in the future is not only a place
of learning but also a place of
experience  and i imagine such
things as the man has now suggested
, for example as an ag yes that one
just
day schools, for example, or that
schools are expanded to all-day schools, that
the range of childcare, or the mistake in the words,
shouldn’t
just be about childcare, it should be about the
students, yes, because the students are to
support their social and
cultural skills  expand through
ags like how do i found something but also
through ag is like i don’t know well yes
theater it’s classic of course
but there are certainly a lot of
other options healthy eating
and solidarity like that
lisa you said you have a
lot to say about them  talked about reform of the education system
and also about the fact that one should
possibly make selections later my
question is what does the ideal
education system look like because I am, for
example, of the opinion that school is not
just a place of development but school
is above all a place
where many students are under pressure to perform
im afraid to go to school because they
getting bad ratings the question
is are grades still up to date
or should there be another concept
such as individual
learning progress progress rating
is a very important exciting question
i am also interested in i
unfortunately cannot study social sciences and
educational sciences at the same
time so my answer is
probably there  a bit short
i'm also a big fan of
reformed schools and also of reformed
kindergartens so where you might start with
the grades from there now
in berlin you start with the grades from
the third grade i think that was
that when  i went to school but i
have also heard of schools where this is
only the case from the ninth grade
[music]
waldorf students are not necessarily
disadvantaged just because they only
get grades from the tenth grade i
did my bachelor's degree  with i
think five students and the goods  n
at least everyone is just as competent and
talented as everyone else, but there
is no disadvantage in
doing so, congratulations, that is itself a very good success and then ask yourself what
are you actively doing to
achieve what you demanded in the tenth
grade or whatever  i that in
school the sea is made that you
do entrepreneurship that you also try
to gain experience what do you offer
specifically in your region where you
are so what i do specifically i
can answer very simply i
hire had your trainees or i take
People also come to my internship where I
say even if the school
grade or something doesn’t fit
I just give people a
chance and they can get a taste and
just have a look it doesn’t fit it
just because they might
not be good at math  has the right grade
it doesn't mean that if he
finds exactly his thing it's not his that
was with me was  it was like that back then i was
n't the very best student now i
wasn't the worst student i
was such a good average
i could have got much better grades
but maybe i was too
lazy because i wasn't that
interested today i'm very good with what i
do  very diligent because i enjoy
it and because i also see success yes
or no in germany you stay poor
if your own parents were
already poor well there is a chance
that it will be the case that you will stay poor if
your parents stay on yes but you have to
just be nothing so basically yes
advancement is possible but it is connected with
several and ultimately the
question arises was
it worth it yes what price do you
pay for it and
that’s why mixed you just got
the feeling that there are many from
this milieu  I
have absolutely no contact so
I can't say that
it also works with d  this process of ascent is
accompanied by absolute social
alienation or distancing from
one’s own origins just because my
parents are now rich, for example,
i will be rich at some point too, it can happen,
yes, that can happen, but it can
also happen that they say
hey, I’ll take care of them  completely different
things and may never make it to
the top, so here again
it really depends on the
settings where do I want to go what
do I also believe that there is more
to it than just the will and
I also feel a bit attacked
if you perhaps put forward
the thesis everyone can do it
he just has to want to somehow yes there are
so many reasons why people
don’t make this ascent there can also
simply there can also simply be
strokes of fate commission
illnesses of the parents own chronic
illnesses yes and that’s it too
scientifically proven that people
from a low a  from a low
social background, even if you make it up the
ladder and even people who have
a degree
may still not decide in
favor of the right
job for you
, simply because
you feel like a stranger there, for example they
have a master’s degree, but yes
, then they apply  im put you in the
right position because you feel
strange you talked about the social in strangers
i find that very
interesting we live in a world that is
becoming more and more connected nevertheless
those who made it or who were
simply born nice up there can’t have it
at all  more with us people
slipping through the net below you see the
same general pub but everyone
looks at their own mobile phone it would
happen to me what do you think we have to do
in politics to overcome this alienation
and how to get
more acceptance for a
politics of solidarity again  win yes so I'm quite
fro  h that the
social background has now been included as a
dimension in the diversity charter that is
an important step to begin with,
however, these should not just
be empty words in any way, but
maybe also speak sir, that
means that, for example, companies
are more aware of the  look at characteristics
could the workers bring children with
them, so
problem-solving skills through attitude
perseverance they are
goal-
oriented yes, there are definitely characteristics that workers' children
bring with them
[music]
so what could I recommend I think
recommend this is definitely this this
ag there is in the  school that you
maybe have a mentor
at your side where one or the other
may not have vitamin b that you
have support there and maybe
you can ask one or the other
question where you maybe don't dare
to ask your parents or where  you
might think where should my
parents get that from  knowing that's one thing the
other is
there are such networking events
that are also usually free of charge
you can do it completely
online today so you do
n't even have to feel like
you're there anymore because your name is so
we'll look at them on linkedin ammann but if
the i'm always a writer here now
that's because it's easier for the
majority of society to digest this name
and to work with it
yes that's a good point i
really only do it because it's
easier for them  say that most of the
time because i have a cool
mnemonic with me because i always
say hey my name is as i mentioned
and people can easily remember
that i say it is crisp and that
fits now as ghosts they have
the name but actually yours
identity do you feel you feel well
so sometimes feels lonely
do you feel like did
you feel strangers and do you feel distance  rt
from the social background or
maybe not because your parents
made this ascent together with you if they have also become so
enterprising by
owning their own battery or
indian departments i can answer the hat
myself and i feel
fit i want me  not in strangers 9 if
you could now change a thesis of the other
what would that be well the one
with you is what for me the standard
statement the the aces everyone can
do it i would wish that
you
think more diverse yes and not just about
people with maybe the same way
as you but just an even more complicated
black background i think you
don't have to have studied today to find your
way i would say you have to
have studied today to find your way
which i can recommend to the people
out there  makes a lot of internships is
that you have to tell the schools
that i had more support in
mine back then  school career two internships
done at praktiker when he was
nothing there are people who
want twelve internships i did four internships
at least half of which was paid and
paid so many internships
can only be said by someone
who can afford it
, you can tell
politicians sometimes just have to
listen all the time and
i think that's what it comes down to and then do what
means doing to enable social advancement up here
i think we have to fight child poverty in
our country very massively we
need better basic security for
people with low income we
need a higher minimum wage i
know in the discussion it is a
bit of a pity that social advancement was
only linked to the
educational qualifications it was pretended
that you and your degree were worth something
and professional training per se
is worse believe that  is not at all
like that with one with the
Vocational training can lead to your
own company
or to self-employment much more quickly,
as we were told, for example, and
that is why it is very important that we
don’t
ride up something hierarchical in some way, but as it
is very individual that we have to
see how  let's make sure that
everyone can develop their talents and their strengths
and not just look at formal qualifications as much as
we like to do in germany
it
was very much about the would all
possible solutions, for example to
compensate for social disadvantages
, let's found someone ag here
mentoring program and then we
compensated for the disadvantages but
it really has to be about
changing social power structures and
preventing structural discrimination so it's not about
equal opportunities it's about us
starting conditions i think germany
is a country that everyone has the  offers a chance to
advance we have
also worked very hard politically in recent years to ensure
that the framework conditions
are such that everyone has the opportunity to advance
what we can still
improve we will
certainly have to tackle that in the next legislative period
but germany is really
a country where it is  one succeeds in moving up through all
levels of society to
seize opportunities to seize educational
opportunities but also
to enter the market professionally yes i found the
discussion very exciting because it
showed two very different people who made it and
also showed the hurdles they
both encountered  are and that
underlines once again that
although we make social advancement possible in Germany,
it makes it
very difficult for some people and
that we can make it easier for them
and that is why it is important out of here
finds great truths in both parts
and
[music]
the int  I was interested in the reality
getting ahead beginning of the summer spirit of schengen of the
episode flipping of the script preparing
for the episode where we asking you on
social media like wannabe path of the
decade
[Music]